I think lots of a homemakers have this Assumption
that there is some way out there to make life easier.
Like some tips,
some trick that we just don't know.
Something that makes the day easier
and keeps the household together.
Something that keeps the Mills keep on coming.
And the house clean,
the children happy and educated.
And the grass mode,
the animals fed.
But in all reality,
there is no real trick to it.
It's just repetition,
hard work. Keep going,
keep waking up,
keep your smile on your face.
And just keep the Mills coming.
Although with practice and education,
these tasks become easier,
more enjoyable,
and more fulfilling.
When you get things right,
the food tastes better,
the education flows easier.
But this is just your encouragement.
To let you know that there is no real trick.
You're not doing anything wrong.
Just keep on going. Repetition,
education. Practice makes everything easier.